wir gehen jetzt in Minecraft rein ja
wieso steht bei Sandra stinkez ich weiß
nicht warum aber wir wurden auch in der
letzten Folge schon im letzten Stream so
ein bisschen geprankt
vielleicht dass unser mapersteller ein
kleiner lustiger pranker ist apropos
prank übrigens Leute s hör mich nicht
heute ist natürlich auch wieder ein
prank
geplant hab übrigens neues Wort BRE ich
sag das ganz
oft alles gut BRE verstehst du mich dann
überhaupt was ich d meine nee weiß gar
nicht was BRE heißt eine Katze ist
[Musik]
tot ein paar mehr holzster jetzt zwei
jetzt spinst du du bist
frech warum hast du mir gestern alles
Gute zum Geburtstag gewünscht es war
welthundetag gestern kleiner Hohn wir
sind gerade bei Block
1625 sind wir kann es sein dass du dumm
bist was
was die schreiben alle bei mir in chat
52 Idiot 25 da stand 52 habe ich doch
gesagt
1625 hey ich habe deine Cola Cola Zero
Werbung auf tiktok gesehen lu hat die
mir auch geschickt la hast du die
Kommentare darunter durchgelesen nee ich
hatte das nur als Anzeige bei mir
deswegen hat ich Kommentare sind also
ich nehme SAS nicht für ernst aber
jemand schreibt die Kommentare sind
erschreckend die Leute haben
kommentieren als ob die Cola Zero
trinkt halt's Maul ja das halt auch so
voll der Unterschied h oh mein Gott oh
nein sind die sind die Schweine los
[Musik]
self Ciao Leben
ah er hat unser Schild er hat unser
Schild
[Musik]
ach du scheiße der ist ja unzerstörbar
ciao
Alter was war das für
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein oh mein Gott Alter Laser ich bin ja
gar nicht ready dafür oh mein Gott war
der stark du mal kurz ab ich muss mal
eben kurz meine Items sortieren mein
Inventar schon wieder voll ist muss ich
nicht ich habe Idee für ich hätte die
Idee dass Sandra nicht aufhört zu
springen mach mir ein
Bananenbrot diese Frau ist am Arsch okay
Sandra wird jetzt die ganze Zeit
hüpfen was ist ich hüpfe die ganze Zeit
du hüpfst ja wie in Minecraft oder wo ja
die ganze
Zeit oh oh oh jetzt darf ich nicht hier
hüpfen ich hüpfe ich drück nichts ich
hüpfe verarsch mich nicht du prankst
mich gerade oder nein e Leute for real
prankt die mich gerade nein
ja geh mal warte ich öffne mal deinen
Stream geh mal vom PC weg nim mal deine
Hände
hoch
wirklich h wie kann das sein ja sie
prankt nee sie prankt nicht oder hat sie
irgendwas auf der letaste drauf ach die
hat wahrscheinlich irgendwas drauf
gelegt
ne sicher wirklich ja ich schwöre warte
ich ma mal die Tastatur an und aus ja
zieh mal vielleicht irgendwie die hinten
kurz raus und steckt dann wieder rein
oder so ein paar Sekunden später er ist
nicht hast du raus wieder
reingesteckt
ja sicher ja ich habe ein Kabel hier
direkt dran okay schreib mal irgendwie
keine Ahnung schreib mal in Chat oder so
irgendwie don't Jump oder so
Ausrufezeichen d o n t und dann Jump
oder
so ja hat was gebracht ja ja diger war
das wieder mapersteller der hier
irgendwas aktiviert
haer wie lange will eentlich aufute
bleiben ist die dum hat die mich auf
Mute ich bin nicht
Mute ach du scheiße ich hö den einfach
nicht seit 5 Minuten gefühlt ich bin
nicht auf ich rede die ganze Zeit mit
von HL erschlagen das die prank mich ne
mach mir ein
ban wie die lacht man hört doch wie die
lach oh nein das Haus
explodiert so erstmal das Holz sortieren
oh nein SAS Hund ist
gestorben Leute wisst ihr hört die mich
wirklich
nicht
warum
antwortest du nicht Leute l geseen warum
antwortest du nicht ist der dumm du bist
dumm hör nicht guck mal hier hier ich
rede und sie redet auch hier ist ja auch
ein grüner Kreis die prank dich safe sie
hört dich man hört dich in ihrem Stream
20 Sekunden später s du kannst auflösen
ich habe gesehen dass man mich hört in
deinem Stream die ist so gottlos man
hört mich in ihrem Stream und sie macht
trotzdem weiter mit ihrem dummen prank
die lacht sogar da kam gerade ein
Lachen kein Bock
mehr ich Kopfhörer nicht auf ich habe
die mir runterzogen als ich mein Ohr
gekratzt habe okay also zusammengefasst
du hast mich wirklich nicht gehört nein
ich habe dich nicht gehört Laser meiner
Ansicht nach sind es Geschichten aus dem
paulanergarten la und ich wollten no ein
Roadtrip machen aber irgendwie die die
die Zeit die rennt was soll ich euch
sagen ja das allernächste was aber auf
jeden Fall erstmal geplant ist Sand die
können wir auch schon mal sagen oder
Leute ich sag's mal so freut euch sollen
wir soll wir sagen soll ich
Trommelwirbel machen ja haltet
euch und
ich willst du sagen oder soll ich sagen
ich habe jetzt extra TR du sagst
jetzt ja scheiß drauf diger wir gehen
auf Tour wir gehen auf Tour und das
Ganze tatsächlich schon nächsten Monat
in einem Monat ja ja wir hatten
irgendwie weil das jetzt so viele mal
wir haben die Idee ja seit seitdem wir
den Podcast gestartet haben seit
irgendwie Z D Jahren jetzt haben das so
viele gemacht und es sah so cool aus bei
allen dass wir jetzt gesagt haben diger
wir müssen jetzt auch mal langsam wir
machen aber was ganz kleines wir machen
vier Städte machen wir nur kann man die
schon sagen ich glaube ja sind die vier
größten Städt in Deutschland Hamburg
Berlin München bzw München vielleicht
auch Stuttgart keine Ahnung und Köln
kann man auch mit 14 hin ich ich weiß es
nicht keine Ahnung vielleicht mit
Begleitperson dann denke ich ja schauen
wir mal was wird also wir werden da
natürlich noch mal genau euch bescheid
geben wann wie was online ist aber man
kann nur leider schon mal sagen ich weiß
h so dumm promoäßig an aber man muss
wirklich schnell sein weil wir halt
wirklich gesagt haben wir möchten das in
einem kleinen Rahmen lassen also was
heißt klein kleinen Anführungszeichen
wir haben in jeder Location nur 1000
Plätze und ich habe la auch gesagt wenn
die nichtkau
bekommen Set ich stasten da rein ja hat
gesagt wenn wir 1000 Leute nicht voll
bekommen bei der Show dann kauft sie die
letztlich die restlichen Tickets und
setzt da irg welche Leute rein die S auf
der Straße
kennenlernen 2 € wäre akzeptabel
akzeptabel wä es eigentlich wenn wir
euch Geld geben würden dafür oder al
wirklich 24 Stunden und 12 Stunden
Stream machen wir auf jeden Fall im
Winter also auf jeden Fall jetzt bald
demnächst innerhalb der nächsten 4 f
Wochen ich sag euch nach der IDA bin ich
100% Fokus wieder drauf Freunde das
war's mit Minecraft one block heute zwar
nicht so lang wir waren jetzt nur eine
Stunde 15 hier drin allerdings gehen wir
jetzt in Mario Party rein ich ma noch
eine
Kiste okay Lais okay Freunde das war's
mit Minecraft
[Musik]
oneblock